hey everyone this is Steve with collider
and we are here at our Sundance studio
in Park City uh before we get started I
want to give a huge thank you to film EO
for being our sponsor it really costs a
lot of money to be here and they're
allowing us to Champion independent
cinema and films like uh you guys and
the Fantastic doc but uh if you're not
familiar with filo uh they're shattering
the barriers by placing the power to
Greenlight films in the hands of
creators and fans and you can learn a
lot more about them at
film. how are you guys doing great great
to see you sorry for being late oh
please uh I just want to give I I it
costs a lot to be here so having a
sponsor it really makes a huge
difference um I really want to start
with right at the beginning I I was
going to curse loved this documentary so
much I am a huge huge fan of your father
and what you guys did with this uh I
think anyone who is a fan of Chris reev
is going to love this film uh and I'm
just so happy you guys are here so we
can talk about it um no one has seen it
yet including Sundance so how have you
guys been describing it or who wants to
explain uh what the doc is about go
ahead be oh
thanks that's great when you too you can
just give the bucket to the other one
pass the buet I mean we started this
film uh because we knew this story so
well we grew up with it um and uh and so
it was a very easy film for us to sort
of start describing you know you had um
the greatest Cinema superhero the
original Cinema superhero on screen uh
and you had this person who after his
tragic accident became a a true hero in
life and that is a just a lovely concept
to play with um and then we met these
guys and the film became about so much
more it became about about family and it
became about love and um Legacy and
about an extraordinary Legacy well I'm
curious so you guys were working on this
prior to you guys being involved like
how did that come about because it's
without you three in this it's a
completely different movie I think
that's a question for you maybe guys
yeah so I mean it all started um uh with
a cold email that we received uh from an
archive specialist um who uh we had a
zoom call with and we you know wanted to
then take it to a production company
that's when we approached passion
pictures um and then uh passion pictures
uh
suggested Ian and Peter as directors and
I said a note to these guys like you got
to check out McQueen and Rising Phoenix
and basically based on their previous
work we're like I think this is them
like they're the they're the right guys
for this um and then we jumped on a
couple calls with them and got to know
them and um and and got on well and um
and it all sort of came together quite
organically and quite quickly well I'm
just curious had you three been thinking
about making a film before why was now
the right time
we had talked casually just as siblings
over the years about potential projects
or the idea of any sort of project and
we came to the conclusion that it needed
to be the right time with the right team
and this year is 20 years since our dad
died so it felt like if we were ever
going to do something like this if we
were ever going to tell this story uh in
the way we wanted it told it would this
year felt like the right time and then
as we met Ian and Peter and the folks at
passion pictures and misfits
entertainment and words and pictures we
knew we had the right team and at that
point we said we trust you we believe in
you and we are here to give you whatever
you need but go do your thing go make
this the way you want to make it because
we trust and believe in you and we've
been rewarded Beyond Comprehension it's
really lovely we knew that we were going
to be handing over an archive maybe
sitting for interviews but beyond that
we were going to completely relinquish
control so it matter to find the right
people who would tell the story
authentically there's a way you can tell
the story just focusing on kind of you
know the glossy polished exterior that
sometimes people think about but to show
the highs and the lows to show the
public Persona and then what was life
was like behind the scenes um really
like that takes people with a real gift
and we were able to find that in these
two and sorry just to follow up on your
question before about um you know what
is the film about they answered it so
eloquently but I would just add that
it's the story of a hero but it's not
propaganda it's not like geography um
our father lived an extraordinary life
and the things that he did and
accomplished and fought for made him
hero and we knew that however they told
the story as long as it was authentic
and real and unflinching that's the
story that would end up being shared
with the world and that's what we have
which is such a treit I was just going
to say I mean I remember when we first
met we sort of talked about the idea of
not putting your dad on a pedest stall
which it it would be so easy to do
because he was a gorgeous man he did
extraordinary things he his example was
so inspiring it's very easy to sort of
like make a kind of like uh glib heroic
portrait of someone and we wanted to
kind of make sure that we showed him
Flaws and All um really and because that
actually deepens how you feel about the
heroic things that he did oh man I have
so many questions but I want to ask you
guys I have friends that are actors
and when I'm watching them on screen I
sometimes see my friends and I sometimes
see the the act the person they're
playing so for the three of you when you
watch your father's work do you see your
dad or can you watch the movie I know
it's a good question I see moments of
him for sure there there the I think
every actor brings an element of
themselves into a role um uh a lot of
the times absolutely not he you know it
kind of becomes like a a transformation
and you're if you're absorbed in the
story and and the character you kind of
won't think about it but there were
moments like certain looks and smiles
that you know we were privileged enough
to see you know off camera in our
everyday lives and uh yeah absolutely
you do notice those things I think it's
what made the having a film like this so
special so we are now at the point you
know I have two children Matthew has two
children and for them to see not only
you they watch the films and they really
see an actor but they went to watch this
documentary and they see the person
behind the scenes really brought to life
which has been beautiful and kind of an
unintended consequence of I wasn't
thinking about them as a target audience
for this we want the world to hear the
story but seeing this family kind of
come to life and all of the archive
footage that's pulled together so
beautifully and this film has really
made a huge difference too I don't know
if you want to add I there's nothing
they they crushed it they uh I feel the
same way we we tend to see things the
same way so I'm curious for the two of
you um obviously the film this Doc uses
footage from the Superman films and
other things how tough was it to get the
clearance and you know to be able to use
that footage because obviously that
footage really really helps sell
everything because you know you remind
the audience of what he looked like a
Superman and you can you know what I
mean but it it would work without the
footage but the footage really helps um
yeah I mean as soon as you're going to
make a film about a massive movie star
which has worked for some of the bigger
Studios you're going to have a lot of
challenges to get the to get the the
licensing but you know we
warned the you know the people the team
and we worked at it and it took a bit of
time but you know
people you know it's it's they want to
celebrate as well the legacy of you know
he as Peter eloquently said earlier you
know he's the ultimate superhero and
superheroes have moved on to become such
big part of our popular culture but the
the the original story is Christopher
Riv in the first Superman so I think
Warner Brother are very proud of that
Legacy so no we it took it some time but
we we we got there in the end and you
know it's one of the challenge of when
you make retrospective documentary with
Lords of archive but to tell you the
truth I think to the point of Al
actually all of you guys I think some of
the great footage that you actually shot
Matt and you know you guys did is is the
most magical one because I think people
when you watch a documentary about
someone which is famous you want to go
behind the scene and you want to
discover more about the human being you
want to be connected you want to see the
the small tiny detail of daily life I
mean I love the way the film starts and
when then I give you a bath in the in
the sink I mean give myself a bath in
the sink my and the way she says as well
I love that says oh for posterity
everybody will have seen me like this in
the morning that if she knew now that
actually everybody will see her like the
way she looked in the morning but how
she grow to become a hero herself is um
is is fantastic so yeah the we needed
Superman and the story is about Superman
and that's the way we carve The
Narrative but at the same time we have
just love the behind the scene I just
love and as Peter said we made a film
about their family and how the children
take to on the Legacy further oh listen
again I can only say how much I love
this film so many times but it's because
of everything it's the Superman footage
it's you guys being so um honest and
sharing like your real emotions I I
loved it I am curious with the editing
process because you could have made a
three-hour movie you could tell a you
know what I mean how challenging was it
to cut it down to the length that it was
did you ever have a much longer cut or
like story lines that you had to remove
yeah there we
go I think I mean the thing is that we
had
a a kind of a a road mapap for how we
wanted to tell the story um through the
flashbacks and the use of of telling the
story post accident and and his life
before the accident so we knew that and
we we knew how we were going to how we
wanted to stitch it together but we had
so much amazing material so many
extraordinary anecdotes and our first
cut was about was it 3 hours 40 minutes
yeah something like that can I ask is
that a cut that you were like happy with
or was that like yeah it was like an
assembly cut of it it was more or less
an assembly I mean our our working
progress is like it's almost like
sculpturing or puzzle making so you've
got loads of parts of the film but he
doesn't sing yet and the film finds
itself we help finding it but suddenly
the emotional journey of the film finds
itself you know we were talking about it
again yesterday night it's just there
are a moment where you have to make
decision but the decision is for the
good of the film and it's not because of
length sometime sometime think people oh
90 minutes we need to hit 90 minutes but
sometime the film calls out for that and
we could have gone down in loads of
different direction but in the end we're
very happy with what we have but as I
said it's just we have this raw material
three hour 3 hours and 40 minutes and
you chip at it bits by bits and sometime
you just like oh my God if we overstay
our welcome emotionally in this moment
then we lose the audience you always
work with an audience you know if you
make a a humorous and a joke in it and
we've heard a lot of people laughing
lately with it um you just want to make
sure that it doesn't you know it doesn't
become corny or other St is welcome
again so it's it's it's just you know
it's just music you know sometime you
overwrite music it's like you over paint
you over you know it's just you just got
to brush it exactly yeah it's kind of
building tension and then where you
release tension and then where you have
a a slightly more epic grandiose moment
and contrast that with something very
personal and very intimate a and as as
you were implying it's sort of like
there's a there's a wonderful point in
the process where the film starts
telling you what it needs and what it
doesn't need and that can be painful
because you're losing material that you
you've kind of love and it's been in
your head since the beginning of the
project but suddenly you just have to it
you know you just have to sort of obey
what the film needs and say uhuh go
we've got a really we just say it
because he hates us mentioning it but
we've got a great Ed editor Oto bonam um
he just doesn't want us to mention the
name too much but we have a great system
where the three of us if two of us
agrees on something then the third one
has to back down but in a way we the
first audience a filmmaker and his
editor is the first run of audience we
are the one triing those emotional
moments those grandious moment what does
inspire us what makes Christopher Reef
so big but what makes Christopher is so
vulnerable you know at one point in his
life he could not spend a single second
without anyone where at the beginning of
his life he's probably the most
independent strong intelligent person
you could ever come across flying the
Atlantic twice on his own do you see
what I mean and that journey is just
it's you know it's a movie again where
am I going to go with my next question
um we can't make them up for you don't
way no no I I I am there's so much I'm
want to ask and I have like five minutes
left um so one of the things is I'm
actually curious for the three of you
when you grow up with a dad who is is an
actor of his stature uh how much in your
head were you thinking about acting in
any way shape or form as like a career
and how much were you sort of like I
don't want to do this I know you know
what I mean I do know what you mean um
it turns out that you need to have
talent to succeed and I and that that
was one limiting factor I realized
myself just speaking for myself and I do
now work in sort of I'm on camera I'm a
correspondent for ABC News so it's sort
of a jent in a in a way um that I'm out
there in front of a camera but I acted
in school plays and enjoyed them and
people I think naturally will ask oh do
you ever think about asking I still to
this day get asked like oh you should
play Superman I'm like I have brown eyes
and I can't act that's the problem like
I that that's what it comes down to and
I learned firsthand that to succeed and
you see it here at the festival all of
these people who dedicate all of their
being to their art and to the projects
that they make you need to need it like
you need air to breathe and I didn't and
so I realized that if I'm an ambitious
person like I am and I want to succeed
at whatever I do it's not going to be
acting because I don't crave it I saw in
my dad and my mom who was so talented as
an actor and a singer they need like
they needed it it sustained them and I
didn't have that so I never even
bothered to try we do joke that we
divided our dad's interest between the
three of us professionally so I
inherited the advocacy Gene I live in
Washington DC I leave a nonprofit
advocacy organization Matthew is a
filmmaker and a writer and will got all
of the on camera star presence so took
three of us to build up his legacy and
following his footsteps but acting
somehow slipped through the cracks well
and he also used to talk a lot about um
how hard it was in the struggle in his
early years and going up for countless
auditions and getting constantly
rejected and not getting parts and it
sort of instilled you know there was
such a passion for the craft and for the
work and also then personally for me I
mean his journey all started in the
theater and I mean I can't memorize like
five lines let alone like five acts and
uh so yeah it quickly sort of became
something that wasn't on like the
Horizon for me at all no and I I
understand you're I understand exactly
look if it's not in your DNA like that
you you know you're not g to succeed
slash want to do it but I want to switch
because one of the things you guys are
um you guys have a foundation that
Champions uh you know um spinal cord
research and injuries and I'm just
curious what can you tell people about
like how where are you in the terms of
how are things going uh how's progress
going are stem cells a huge part of it
like what can you tell people about it
well one of the things we're so proud of
is that our dad had a legacy in many
ways but watching the growth of the
Christopher and Dana re foundation and
so many more people caring on that work
is being really beautiful so in the
medical research field we seeing
unbelievable progress stem cells was one
part of it but also the extreme Focus my
dad had on physical therapy in the film
you'll see him the amount of hard work
that he put in every single day and that
he started to get some recovery as a
result of that that was early stages and
we're now seeing many more people get
benefits through the type of work that
he was doing and then the advocacy he
was doing on behalf of the disability
Community as well I mean you know he was
one of the people in the '90s fighting
for an end to Lifetime caps on insurance
we finally got that in the afford Care
Act in 2008 so he didn't get to live to
see it but there are all of these pieces
that we see where he was out there
fighting and others have now carried on
the work in a really beautiful way and
the work continues
because the the foundation has a a dual
Mission and my mom thrust into the role
of caregiver learned firsthand how
difficult it is to care for a loved one
with a spinal cord injury and she
realized that she had resources that
millions of other people in the same
situation might not have and she wanted
to help them and figure out a way to be
a resource so we created the paralysis
resource center and give out millions of
dollars in Grants to help individuals
and organizations who need the help and
we're funding Cutting Edge research and
it's all over the map now the the paths
to cures are more wide open and more
inspiring than maybe they've ever been
with the proliferation of technology and
I will say as a proud son a lot of that
is due to the visibility that my dad
gave that our dad gave that Community um
I have a plaque in my home it's a cover
of a Wall Street Journal that someone
turned into like a bronze thing it says
the Reeve effect and it's a graph a
chart showing the funding dollars and
general awareness of spinal cord
injuries pre 1995 when he was injured
and post and it's a hockey stick off the
chart and that has only continued and so
our work only continues we're proud
board members at The Reef foundation and
we're as involved as we could be I was
going to say that one of the reasons why
I love this documentary is it's also
going to remind people about the
importance of funding research and
raising awareness and uh but Mo I mean
it's just such a fantastic film you guys
are going to be getting such great
reviews out of the Fest um I know we you
have to do other press and we have more
interviews coming in so I'm just going
to say congratulations a huge thank you
again to filo for being our sponsor
because I wouldn't be able to be here
talking about your film without them and
I wish you guys nothing but the best and
thank you so much for coming
in thanks so
much